翻訳: Ai Tokimatsu
校正: Yasushi Aoki
皆さん お疲れさまです
安宅です
日本が今ある状態と
我々のチャンスについて
ちょっと話してくれないかということで
やってきました
タイトルは『シン・ニホン』と
（笑）
何故かということは
だんだんわかってくると思うんですけども
今 私達がですね
置かれている状況というものを
ちょっとまあリキャップ的に
したいんですけれども
一番 この30年ぐらいで私が思う
世の中で一番起こっている変化は
コンピューターを持ち歩くことだと
思っています
30年前のスパコン
一番速かったクレイのコンピューターの
数十倍速いコンピューターを
皆さんがポケットに持っています
iPhone 6で20倍速かったんです
7 以上持っている人は
もっと速いです
とんでもなく速いコンピューターを
皆さんは持ち歩いているんですね
なおかつ 帯域が異常な勢いで
増えていっています
だいたいこの十数年で
千倍以上になりました
私が働いているYahoo! Japanが
できてから20年間で
１万倍以上速くなっています
そして これから５Gになると
この帯域がもう千倍速くなることが
決まっています
いいですか？
今ですね パケットプランが
15ギガのやつが50ギガになりましたけど
たぶんあと５年から10年でですね
１ヶ月のプランが５テラとかになります
「５テラプラン」の時代が来る！
（笑）
すごい時代なんですね
これがいわゆるビッグデータです
これはめちゃめちゃなログデータが
噴き出してきている訳です
だけど 幸いですね
コンピューターというのはとんでもない
スピードで進化しています
なので チップの数が
異常な勢いで増えてますから
処理できるものが増えていると
もうひとつラッキーなのはですね
このコンピューターのお陰が
結構 大きいんですけど
あとデータのお陰ですね
今までだったら絶対に
可視化できなかったデータが
可視化できるように
なってきています
全く走らなかったニューラルネットワークが
走るようになって
ディープラーニングが動いています
また こういう異常なパターンというかですね
もうデータが多過ぎて
数字の羅列では絶対に
わからないパターンも
見えるようになっている
ということですね
結果として 我々は
これ(産業革命)に近い
異常なタイミングに生きている と
産業革命というのは２〜３百年かけて
起こってきた訳ですけれども
だいたい1800年代になるか
ならなかった頃は
日本もアメリカも 世界中
90%以上の人が第一次産業に
従事していたことがわかっています
アメリカで96%だった
と言われている
でも今 数%しか
働いていないですね
でも我々は全然
生産性高く生きている訳です
それに近いぐらい
私達の今の時間というのは
なんというか
情報処理に使われていますね
これが解き放たれるという
非常に重要な時間というか
タイミングに生きているという
とても面白い時に僕らは生きている
ということが言えるかなと思います
ここに生きているということは
もうやっぱりエンブレースしないといけない
死ぬほどラッキーなことで
超面白い時なんですね
「確変モード」である (笑)
ええ そうなんですよ
過去２千年くらいの
正確に言うと百万年の
人間の生産性を調べたと言い張っている人が
バークレーにいるんですけど
彼によるとですよ
真実かはともかくとして
ローマ時代から産業革命までの
２千年かけて
生産性は２倍にしか
上がっていないです
ただ そこから後ですね
150年かそこらかけて
生産性は100倍近く上がっています
ただ よく見ると
マクロ的には今
若干サチってるんですね
これがもう一発
跳ねるんじゃないかというのが
今 我々が見ている時だと思います
実際にですね 非常に面白い
サインが生まれていて
マーケットキャップのランキングを見ても
上の方はほとんど ICTと呼ばれる
インフォメーション コミュニケーション
テクノロジー系の
企業が並んじゃって
世界最大級のメーカーと言える
トヨタの上にですね
アリババとかAmazonがいるという
そういう時代です
付加価値の総和で見た
GDPで見てもですね
過去20年間で 実は
ICTセクターがなかった日本は
縮小経済であった
ということがわかっています
これは実は世界的にも
大体どこ見ても似たような傾向にあって
成長のドライブというのは
この ICTになっています
しかも 面白いのはですね
この利益よりも 遥かにこのICT系の企業というのは
マーケットキャップが大きくて
「世の中を変えている感」というのが
富につながるという
つまりですね「妄想力が富を産む」という
驚くべき時代が来ている訳ですよ
国富を産み出すのは
ハードワークというよりも
妄想力の時代になったという
それを頭に置いて
じゃあ どうやってやっていったら
良いのかということなんですが
ざっくり言うと３つのことが
非常に重要だという風に考えています
１つは非常に多くのデータをマッシブに
色んなところに使うということですね
２つ目はそれを非常に強烈な力で
安くガンガン処理をかける と
３つ目は当然 非常に世界レベルの
サイエンティストやエンジニアが入って
ガンガンやるという
ことなんですが
これちょっと非常に語られることが珍しい
日本の不都合な真実がありまして
まず最初のデータ
これは あの —
正直 勝負になっていないです
全てのフィールドにおいて
全く勝負になっていないです
データを使うという話でですね
今 自動走行車とか
色々ありますけれども
それの手前でですね
ルームシェアリングとかカーシェアリングとか
データを使う産業が
色々あるんですけれども
これらはほとんど保護されていて
できないです
この国ででは ですね
もっと問題なのはですね
例えば自動走行車っていう
たぶん自動走行車を
世界一作る国が
日本になる可能性が
結構高いんですけれども
日本の道はこんな感じで —
無理です！
（笑）
無理なんです！
あのですね 向かいから来た
オバチャンがいてですね
気合いとかでですね
お前 よけろとか言って
人の家の中に入ってですね
場合によっては10mくらい
バックしてすれ違うとかいうのは
自動走行車にはできません
完全に止まっちゃうんです
この話は技術で解決しろっていう人が
いるんですけど
いや できますよ
空飛ぶ車とかね
足生やすとか
もう３千万になりますよ 車がね
それは無理なんですね
ドローンを飛ばそうとしても
見た通りですね
いいですか？ これ
東京都港区
平屋と50階建が混在しています
パリとかは ほとんどフラットですね
エッフェルタワーしかないんで
ドローンゾーン使えば
飛ばせるんですけれども
これができないんですね
またデータ処理ということで
見るとですね
そもそもデータプロセシングコストというのは
電気代なんですけれども
もう勝負になってなくてですね
なんかよくわかんないくらいに
データ処理に金がかかる と
しかもそのソリューション
というところを見ると
これは本当に何というか
ごく一部ですけれども
ほとんど日本という国の
プレゼンスはないですね
ということで非常にデータプロセシングにおいて
日本はビハインドです
というか ものすごく
ヤバい状態なんですね
そこの技術の１つの核心である
ディープラーニングの
キーセンターと言うべきところが
あるんですけれども
この辺の人達というのは
この業界の人は皆詳しいんですが
有名人です
もう全部 海外です
北米および英国に集中しています
こういう状態です
エンジニアくらいいるだろうと
皆さん思われるかもしれないんですけれども
確かにいます 結構いるんです
でも日本は アメリカの３分の１です
ここの真ん中の
ミッシングというところがミソで
当然 日本人は無意識のうちに
アメリカの次だと思っているんですが
そんなことはなくてですね
中国とインドには負けているんですね
こういう状態でですね
ビッグデータ人材というのは
もっと少なくて たぶん
もっと下 ７、８番目の可能性すらあると
ナンバーを触っていく人自体がですね
足りないんですね
サイエンスやテクノロジー系の
大学卒業性の数というのは
実は１年あたりでですね
人口５千万の韓国より
10万人以上少ないです
なぜかというと
韓国だとかドイツっていうのは
テクノロジー立国だという意識が強いんで
大学生が６割以上理系なんです
日本は２割なんですね
私みたいに博士課程とか行ったら
変態扱いされちゃう
すごいヤバイ生き物なんですよ
「何でなんだろう？」という
こういう状態ですよね
アナリティカルなトレーニングを
受けた人の数も超少ないです
100人あたりでアメリカの
３分の１しかいなくて
数学大国のポーランド
みたいなところから比べると
１桁少ない訳ですね
これは人間の数だけの問題ではなくて
プログラムもすごい足りていないです
データサイエンスのプログラムというのは
アメリカも全然なかったんですけれども
たった１年で500を超したんですが
日本はようやく今度の春に
滋賀大学にできるぐらいで
全くないという状況です
これは人が足りないという
問題なんですけれども
しかもですね そういう人は
発見するのが困難なだけじゃなくて
あんまり産業的なことを
やる気がないんですよ
皆さんがエジソンに
なれるような時代なのに
全然やる気がないということで
我々に必要なのは
オタクではなくて
やっぱり「世の中を変えるんだ」というですね
こういうハッカーとかギークみたいな
人達が必要なんですけれども
ちょっと足りていない と
ということで 勝負になっていない訳です
まあ何というかですね
こういう時代がありましたよね
結構ヤバかった時があった訳ですね
限りなく何もない状態に
戻ってしまっている
じゃあ 日本に希望はないのか？というと
産業革命を振り返ってみるとですね
これ実は 大きく３つくらい
フェーズがある訳です
1570年代後半からの
こういう新しい技術が生まれた時代があって
それがまあ 応用が出てきて
そして更にですね エコシステムというべき
非常に複雑に絡み合ったものが
できていったと
日本はどうしていたかというと
フェーズ１ ちょんまげを結っていてですね
９割以上の人は田んぼを耕していました
100年以上田んぼを耕していたので
あんまり参加していないんですよね
でも突然やって来てですね
こういう風にですね
ぶち切ったという過去があります
そして なんかよくわかんないくらい
すごい新幹線を作ってみたり
そしてスパコンとかも作ってみたりして
すごい国になっちゃった訳ですね
なので フェーズ１に乗り損ねたことは
明らかなんですけれども
まあ気にせずですね —
（笑）
フェーズ２と３が
やって来ることは確実ですから
これに向けて頑張ったら
どうでしょうかというのが
今 ここで皆さんに提案したいことです
（笑）
まだ見込みはありますし
過去もフェーズ１やったこと
ないんですよ この国は
だから気にしなくて良くてですね
（笑）
フェーズ２と３
もうビッグウェーブが来ます！
波に乗る準備をして
乗りましょう ということですね
しかもですね
非常に優れたコンセプトが
この国には一杯あってですね
Ghost in the Shell とかですね
ドラエもんとかですね
なんかヤバいアイデアが
山のようにあってですね
これまさにフェーズ２、フェーズ３
じゃないですか
ね？
（笑）
ネタはあるんです
アイデアはあります
また勝てます！ 私達は！
そして この間やっていた映画で
非常に感動的なセリフがありました
「この国はスクラップ＆ビルドで
のし上がってきた
今度も立ち上がれる」
『シン・ゴジラ』のセリフ
だったんですけれども
まさにですね 非常に面白い局面で
我々はもう ほとんど
スクラッチなんですけれども
もう１回やりましょうよ
ということで
気持ち良く戦えるんじゃないかな
というのが
スッキリとやりましょう
ということで
私の話は以上です
ありがとうございました
(拍手)